[Music]
welcome everyone my name is Raj I'm with
slumber J I'm the kind of fancy title
here Delfy data ecosystem manager today
I'll talk about the petro technical
suite of applications and how we brought
them onto the Google platform some of
the challenges that we faced in how we
work with Google to address these but
before we start let me give you an
introduction to number J particularly
for people who may not be from the oil
and gas industry V or the leader in the
oil and gas services space we have about
100,000 or so employees V or in about 85
different countries from the software
segment which is what I represent
we've got about 70,000 Petro technical
users that are using this we have around
1600 people out of Schlumberger in the
software segment and and about 800
different you know individual clients
that are actually using this software so
when I talk about software what do I
really mean what are these domains and
what problem spaces or we tackling so if
you look at the upstream exploration and
production
that's what EMP here stands for and the
challenges in this space you are looking
at understanding of the subsurface
identifying of the reservoirs then on to
the execution phase in terms of drilling
and completions first and then into
production and the operation space so
our software suite as you can see with
the the different branding names down
below goes across the spectrum all the
way from the exploration side into
drilling and the production not to
forget the economics aspect of things
right and there are some infrastructural
fraud
which I'm showing in the last column
that are really geared towards how do we
wrangle the data how do we bring the
data into these platforms so the users
can work on that if you want so you know
a few years ago the industry sort of hit
a hard spot in terms of the economic
stress if you will so the industry's
goals really changed a few world right
so efficiency and the ability to have
cost control or doing things in a much
more cost-effective way than we had done
before becomes a key aspect for us and
therefore what we were looking for is
how can we tap into all of these cloud
and big data technologies if you will
and sort of bring them into the oil and
gas space particularly in the upstream
E&P and how we can tap into this right
and traditionally where we've been
strong is sort of the physics aspect of
things if you were shown by the domain
both in terms of the human services that
we do in terms of data acquisition or
the execution of the operations
themselves but also in terms of the
software that we provide to the various
groups so effectively this was sort of
trying to marry the expertise that we
have in the domain and the science that
we have within our software and see how
can we complement this with some of the
things that these cloud technologies can
bring into the space so hence was born
Delfy so this is something that we
commercialized to the marketplace last
September we had a global forum a
similar sort of event with our customers
in Europe and this was released back
then so like I said the key aspect here
was to try to bring in aspects around
the cloud in terms of the scalability in
terms of tapping into the data itself
right so there's so many things that you
can do with respect to the physics side
of things but when you are trying to
drive efficiency to the next level you
want to see how much can we do
in terms of automation in terms of
taking away the mundane things that the
whether it's the geoscientist or whether
this is a reservoir engineer or
production engineer will have to go
through on a day-to-day basis right so
sort of bring the data science aspect of
things and supplement that with the the
physics that is there within our
platforms to deliver more in terms of
efficiency and bootstrapping the users
so what I'm showing on the the fall
right or the key quality attributes that
we were looking for and what our
customers were looking for
obviously as we are tapping into the the
cloud we need to make sure that the
system is secure
this is in fact particularly in the
exploration space a lot of what our
customers are doing and how one customer
differentiates themselves with the other
is in the way in their know-how of how
they're processing the data how they're
able to go through an exploration phase
how they're able to identify the
reserves properly if you will so this
becomes a key differentiating factor so
if data becomes a key differentiating
factor and we talk about the cloud then
the security aspects becomes absolutely
key and this is an aspect where we've
spent a lot of time so this is one of
the architectural principles that to us
is a non-negotiable exactly for this
reason right so everything else in terms
of functionality all the things below
that you see on the list comes after we
made sure that the system is secure data
centric is what I I touched upon in
terms of being able to bring the data
science aspect of things and then
supplement that with what our platforms
are able to do openness and
extensibility becomes a key aspect so in
our current suite of applications we
have a extensibility platform that we
call ocean so these are set of api's by
which our clients third party in fact
there's a lot of competitors who have
tapped into it as well to bridge their
offerings into what
she lumber J has been bringing into the
marketplace so the same concept has to
extend into the cloud we realize that
our customers or working on things
that's way beyond just the the set of
tools and workflows that we are going to
be providing to them and the other
aspect of the cloud that we can sort of
tap into is the collaborative and the
personalized aspect so unlike other
industries this is a place where you
have people that are working in
far-flung areas out in the field there
are people that are working in the
offices across different countries we
are operating in 85 different countries
so you can imagine the the challenge of
distribution and collaboration that is
necessary the expertise typically lives
in the headquarters right so there are a
few experts that that are centralized
and in the rest of the teams are
distributed so how do you bring the
right personalized interface to get them
all to collaborate and work together as
a team so this becomes a key challenge
and last but not the least a lot of
these things and in fact there was an
interesting talk yesterday that I went
to our own from Baker Humes was talking
about what they were doing on the
machine learning side and he was talking
about uncertainty so this is a key
aspect of our industry and the challenge
because you don't get to see the
subsurface so there are certain
measurements that we have done in terms
of you know
well logs or in terms of seismic so
these are or in some cases you know core
samples and things like that so there is
little windows of information that you
get and effectively you are trying to
build a model to piece together the rest
of the blanks of you all so as you start
building these layers of information on
top of each other you are introducing
and compounding uncertainties as you go
through
so therefore the ability to de-risk this
when we are trying to take you know
decisions that make a big economical
impact becomes really important and that
we are tapping into the elasticity and
the scalability of the cloud is exactly
that
so instead of being compute limited and
trying out the few capable combinations
that I can try out on trim today could I
burst this into the cloud and make some
decisions that or you know more accurate
bring down the cone of uncertainty if
you will on the various parameters so so
I kept talking about the the different
domains and the challenges so I wanted
to sort of drill down a little bit more
deeper and talk about the different
profiles of users and what types of
challenges and trying to map this into
sort of the IT or the infrastructure
speak so then we can try to map it into
where the cloud technologies can fit in
a few well so let's start off with the
the petro physicist on the top and go
around in a loop so the petro physicist
is typically working with well data and
given the boom then you all have
probably heard about the stuff that's
going on in unconventionals and shale
type of workflows this now has brought
up a ton of wealth now you're talking
about you know hundreds of thousands of
wells and historical data that hangs off
of this so you're talking about you know
millions of logs and and potentially in
the order of tens of millions if not
hundreds of millions in terms of wall
taps and properties that are associated
with it that have been interpreted by
the users so the ability to deal with
high cardinality data sets and be
effectively carrying this consuming this
from a computation capability becomes a
key challenge for petrol faces and today
on Prem we are challenged by you know
how much you can scale up the
workstation for a end-user or how much
we can form out in terms of a local HPC
and its compute capability in terms of
dealing with these right so a lot of the
things that I showed you in the data
column with our products were really
sort of focused on the high cardinality
aspect of things so I'm sort of
providing a data infrastructure that
backs up what the applications would
need then moving on down into the
reservoir engineer so
like I said the the wave you're dealing
with data in our space is there's only a
few measurements that we have the rest
is all built on a digital model that the
users have interpreted on so the
reservoir engineer is a key role where
they're trying to take data that is
coming in from the petrol faces the
geologist the geophysicist blending them
all together to understand what the
reservoir it looks like what the
reserves and their looks like what the
properties in terms of permeability or
fluid flow looks like so then we can
start to plan the the drilling of a well
into the reservoir and then find out how
effectively we can get the hydrocarbons
so therefore the ability to do the
de-risking from an uncertainty
perspective and figure out how many
simulations can we effectively run to
sort of bring that cone down becomes
really key okay and then moving on down
in terms of the flow assurance engineers
so these are people that is or in the
production domain so you can imagine
once we've completed the well and the
well is starting to produce these
hydrocarbons there is a a mix of
materials that are coming in that'll
have potentially an impact on the flow
it'll have an impact on the life span of
the equipment whether these are the
pumps or whether these are the pipe
lines that we've laid out so the ability
to measure and monitor the various
instruments that we have put in look at
this high frequency time series data and
be able to take both control decisions
in near time and be able to understand
the longer-term impact so we can then
plan for either work hours or an
alternative strategy to improve the
field comes into play right so this is
where the production engineers and the
flow assurance engineers come and and
the the high velocity of data that we'll
have to deal with from the various
sensors that's been instrumented so then
moving on to the left the exploration
list so these are typically geologists
but they are looking at it at a much
more abstract scale so how does an oil
company decide if they need to purchase
a particular field how do you know what
the field is worth
so somebody has to understand the the
basin they have to understand the
prospects within that and then define
what a given play is word so effectively
sort of think about this as the abstract
sizing before you can judge you know
what the reservoir looks like and get
into more technical analysis of this so
therefore these are people that are
looking at very large areas the ability
to visualize the data in all of these
areas the ability to scale ibly access
the data for this this wide footprint
becomes really important for them and
sort of that ties into the geophysics so
like I said the the first piece of data
that you probably get into a particular
area is really the seismic data and some
of the seismic particularly in the pre
stack world could be in the order of
terabytes to petabytes and in a post
stacked world it could be in the order
of gigabytes two terabytes so how do you
effectively bring them into a space
where a exploration astoria phases can
zoom and pan in and understand the area
in a very effective manner right so this
is where you know they are actually
interpreting the seismic to understand
you know what sort of faults are in
there what sort of zones are in there in
terms of horizont and surfaces and and
so on and so forth and that sort of
leads into the geologist who then has to
take such interpreted data that is
coming in from the well domain from the
petro phasis and the seismic domain from
the geophysicist and then he's building
a model an approximation of the earth so
then they can start to figure out what
the the properties of the reservoir
looks like in this particular area so a
lot of our customers are really looking
for a way to go beyond models into
actually natively looking at the data
without having to have these
approximations but the models or or a
way to come up with a way to you know
simplify or wrangle the the problem into
a manageable space but even there you
know in the past where this was in the
order of hundreds of thousands to
millions cells it's now getting into the
billions of cells and therefore you can
now imagine simulation type of workflows
the impact of what is being produced or
injected into one model cell on one time
step impacts the neighboring cell so
there's a lot of couple value
extrapolation that our simulators will
have to do and at that particular scale
that becomes a real challenge when it
comes to both the data handling and the
computer capacity so if I were to shrink
all this into a few bullets that we can
talk about in the 50 minutes today these
are the the top five things that I
wanted to summarize so the 3d
visualization from a geophysicist
perspective from a geologists
perspective from an exploration it's
perspective the multi-user collaboration
and how do we bring all of these domains
together so they're all looking at the
data the same way and they're
interpreting the same way so there isn't
a gap or a misunderstanding between the
different domains how do we handle the
large cardinality of data particularly
in the well domain and the large size of
data in the seismic domain how do we
support concurrent simulations and last
but not the least like I said because
these are global customers they are
operating across the globe how do we
deploy these services and if you're now
offering this from a cloud perspective
we need to think about availability and
reliability and all the SLA aspects that
comes along with it because they are now
going to rely on our service for
business continuity so the way we took
the approach in here was obviously you
know we started building a bunch of
workflows that were tapping into the
machine learning aspect of things and
trying to figure out how we can provide
some of these interpretation type of
capabilities using machine learning look
for patterns and logs looks for patterns
and seismic and in a precursor or
delivering some of the interpretation
but the big challenge that we ran into
is if you now start to offer some of
these capabilities on the cloud but then
they are doing the other 80% of the work
on trend now there has to be a constant
data movement back and forth for them to
go from start to finish from a workflow
perspective
so how do we minimize this impact for
the users how do we take the
applications that are using today also
bring them along into the cloud so
effectively you are shifting the center
of gravity of a asset team or a business
unit of a client into the cloud space so
that's what the petro technical suite
and in Delfy came into play so this is
effectively taking our applications that
typically run on desktops most of these
or Windows applications we do have a few
Linux applications so this is where the
user interfaces and this is where the
users are interfacing and then those
rely on two types of capabilities on the
back one is around the data in terms of
app servers database servers and so on
and so forth and the other one is in
terms of the actual physics that's built
in into our numerical simulators and
that's what is classified as engines so
by bringing these into the Google cloud
platform now the user has one place to
go the data is in one place so whether
they are tapping into some of these
native work Delfy workflows and the
native capabilities in terms of machine
learning and automation that we are
bringing in or in terms of continuing
their workflow in the platforms or the
engines that they are used to it's all
in the same environment right so that
was sort of the driver for why we
commercialized the petro technical suite
in Delfy
so what does that look like so let's
take the journey of Patrick for example
so the first thing that we we figured
out this okay what is this profile so if
he said reservoir engineer he logs in
into the Delphi portal so this is
effectively you know a bunch of App
Engine services and kubernetes clusters
that are running in gke and this is
where we manage the overall interface to
the users if you were right so from a
user experience perspective how we
manage the subscriptions understand
which client that they belong to what
datasets they have access to and and so
on and so forth and this is also the
place where we've linked some of the
soft services meaning the Human Services
whether this is support hell consultancy
they may want to acquire new data in
which case we can have our sister
segments come in and and and enable them
with data acquisition and so on and so
forth
and effectively what the portal does is
after it has figured out who the user is
and understands that in this particular
case is the reservoir engineer routes
into a production environment that you
see on the right side where we've got
all of his applications and all of his
data stores right and we know that over
a period of time we need to continue to
update these applications it's not a
one-time shot so therefore from a
continuous integration continuous
delivery perspective we also create a
lab environment so when there is a newer
version of these products that we try
out if the customer has additional
extensions or plugins and things like
that they have built they have one
cohesive environment where they can
actually test and validate the full
end-to-end workflow slumbers J and non
Schlumberger services together and then
qualify that to be promoted into the
production environment the final
visualization of the applications and
how they consume it if you were the
native workflows are all just web
interfaces and so effectively it's it's
ubiquitous access through a browser for
some of these desktop applications that
are really relying on the the
visualization aspects we use thin client
visualization so effectively doing
server-side rendering and in
transmitting the results back into the
browser so again taking those same five
key challenges and then zooming it down
into the petro technical suite portion
of Delfy let's jump into some of the
details and how we went through the
challenges so the first one is around
the 3d visualization right this one is a
key problem for us because if you look
at how most of our users work they have
you know probably dual 4k monitors this
is where they are sitting and
interpreting 8 hours a day if you have
now taken an intensive application like
this and move that into the cloud we
need to make sure that it has the same
level of performance that they are used
to today entre right so just to give you
an analogue to you know how we may watch
a Netflix movie for example you know you
may be sitting on a 4k screen and
watching a movie so it's it's a one-way
stream of data that is coming in from
the server's in this particular case
it's actually a two-way and it's more
than one 4k screen right because every
time the user decides to move pan
interpret click the application has to
react as if the application was running
on a box that's right next to him right
so the ability to work around the
challenges that the internet brings into
this space right so whether this is
things like packet loss
what's the bandwidth a lot of the
customers and particularly some of the
locations that where they are operating
there's no guarantees in terms of the
the right level of bandwidth that they
may have so we need to make sure how
optimally we can design the system so we
can deliver the right level of
experience with the minimum overhead in
terms of the bandwidth requirement and
likewise we also have to think about
from a global deployment perspective how
do we put these applications close
enough so that way the overall latency
I mean assume that the visualization
aspect the computation aspect has no
penalty if the customer is let's say 200
milliseconds away so by the time a frame
comes up and the customer clicks on it
and the application reacts to it you're
looking at a half half a second right
and it may not seem much but if that's
what you work on eight hours a day 40
hours a week
pretty soon that becomes completely
unusable right so therefore the ability
to understand where the user is and
bring the application closer to where
the user is so we can bring it within a
reasonable latency becomes a key
deployment and operational challenge as
well so from a journey perspective where
we started was really on the K 80s
pretty soon we realized that this was
more geared towards the compute rather
than the visualization and where we are
now
is with the p hundred GPUs and I'll talk
about the different
areas or the regions that we have the
service deployed today and that we will
be moving to is towards p4 and this has
been a fantastic journey with Google
where they've been sort of constantly
helping us through this journey there
are a few issues in terms of where we
are with P hundreds because P hundreds
even though technically supports V GPU
is also built more for compute rather
than for visualization so therefore
there are still challenges in terms of
having to bring our own end media grid
licenses and then the machines from a
Google infrastructure perspective go
through a migration even the machines
have to shut down so imagine if you're a
user
you're remotely accessing one of these
applications and the live migration
event hits right so that that becomes a
workflow issue that we are now working
with Google to resolve this with the new
p4 offering that they're bringing online
so this is a video that I shot on my
laptop and effectively what you're
seeing here is our application patrol
that is being served out of Iowa in this
particular case and I'm based in Houston
just sharted in my laptop screen so it's
a 4k screen that's being served across
the the continental US and we are
getting anywhere between 20 to about
3035 frames per second and anything
about 20 then the users perception that
this is actually remote goes away it
feels much more local and immersive so
the other challenge like I said was you
know users or in different locations how
do we bring them together how can they
work in this space together so here I am
showing three different profiles that or
working together and in this particular
case the the client environment was
running out of the South Carolina region
for Google from where we were serving
the applications to these different
users so this brings up a number of
challenges particular
starting with the security side of
things so how do we out of all of these
users on the Internet
identify these users and how do we
identify that these are the users that
also belong to the same tenant of Yule
and therefore can share data and can
collaborate effectively together so the
step one in in that was the
authentication and the authorization
process so we spent a lot of time with
the the firebase team and the Google
team looking at how we can tap into
Google's I am so effectively our users
or mirrored into Google's IDP there are
a few customers including slumber J's
own internal use where we have federated
it with Google and where we haven't
federated with Google we go through a
registration and Delfy which effectively
creates the users in the Google space
that now allows us to do a basic
authentication and get all the benefits
of Google's ability to look for
anomalies and to validate that the
authentication truly comes from the user
and the location and the device from
where they are trusted to access the
applications and then on the back end of
it and this is where the the challenge
for the petro technical suite comes in
is these are applications that are
running on Windows and Linux so they
don't speak AG token or an OAuth 2 token
so effectively we will have to sort of
bridge the gap between a internet
friendly authentication token and what
the desktop applications truly need so
what we do is we have a service called S
or Thor Schlumberger authentication
think of this as a a handshake service
that once Google has validated that this
user is indeed Patrick from coronal oil
we can then turn around and enable an
account and launch the application under
the users account and that's what you
see on the far right by this thing that
we are calling the tenant ad system so
that shadow identity is what we use so
these applications don't have to worry
about cloud-based identities they can
still happily work in the traditional
Windows and Linux space if you will so
here's a video sorry about the fact it's
a little bit
I think once we imported it I lost some
resolution here but what a shot here is
to users so the user has two 4k monitors
and I also opened up my laptop in there
so you can see you know three screens to
4k one HD screen and then the laptop in
the front is designed to illustrate to
you a user who's remote that is looking
at the same screen as what the primary
user is so back to that collaboration
workflow just like we are taking the
output of the application and presenting
it to the user in Houston we can present
the same application interface to a user
that is sitting in California so now
this effectively creates a virtual room
if you will where these people are
looking at the canvas the same way
they're looking at the applications the
the same way and and just as an analog
if you compare this to you know Skype or
a WebEx or a link type of remote sharing
these are not really built for the kind
of 3d acceleration and the interactivity
that you need to be able to foster this
kind of collaboration right so this is
sort of the high end of the spectrum and
that's what that looks like
so then jumping on to the aspect number
three in terms of the data sets and the
challenges there like I said there is
two real extreme categories of Evo one
is on the large data sets so this could
be in the case of seismic terabytes of
data that we may have to bring into an
application space so what is the overall
eye ops that my storage system can
support to be able to deliver that
volume of data particularly in a random
i/o pattern into the applications and
then off on the other end of the
spectrum
remember the petro physicists and
geologists type of workflow that I was
mentioning where they are dealing with
millions of data items in the wellbore
domain and these are really small pieces
of data but higher cardinality of data
so I'm sure you all have had the
experience where if you throw let's say
ten thousand five
into a file system you can see how much
it slows down right so the ability for
file systems and and their ability to
handle both large file random i/o and
small and high cardinality of files and
how you deal with this from a a
directory and the delivery perspective
sort of stresses out the system right so
today what most of our customers are
using or these really high-end
purpose-built systems from the likes of
you know EMC or NetApp and and so on and
so forth
so now imagine trying to bring this into
the cloud so some of our new solutions
they have the advantage of tapping into
Google's elasticity in terms of things
like Google Cloud storage and bigquery
and so on and so forth but what do I do
about applications that still rely on a
surf's file system how do you bring the
same level of performance and these are
you know several hundreds of man years
worth of effort put in into these
applications to make the physics and the
user experience into it so it's not
possible to overnight just revamp the
storage and then switch it over to use a
bigquery or a cloud storage right so
it's going to be a journey so which
means we need to solve this problem in
the interim so we looked at a number of
both open source and commercial
solutions some of the things that I
haven't listed here we looked at things
like aware we looked at net app the the
big challenge that we had was getting
the level of performance that we need
right so particularly in the seismic
space for the sort of visualizations
that you were seeing there we need close
to 400 Mbps in terms of throughput and
it's not a single channel throughput
because this is multiple users that are
concurrently running these applications
so you need multiple channels of
throughput at the same time so how do we
go about doing that so we did a number
of tests with Google and Red Hat was the
other partner that was involved in
helping sort out the implementation if
you will in fact this was one of those
components that we rewrote and rewrote
over and over again
just to fine-tune it to the right aspect
so we ended up with ZFS this is a old
component from Solaris but in
combination with Google we were able to
tune it to provide the right level of
storage back-end if you were and the
other aspect is the memory so this is
this is sort of probably even pushing
Google to the limits in terms of what a
GCE compute VMs infrastructure needs to
look like so as you can see when you're
talking about remote graphics and
dealing with a larger volume of data
visualization we need a high end GPU to
be able to do that to bring enough data
into memory and be able to visualize
this we need a machine that can give the
add user workstation a ton of memory
space so most of our users typically
have you know half a terabyte or
three-quarters of a terabyte on their
workstations today so how do we get the
amount of memory that is necessary to
hold this data up and do the
visualization and then on the back end
of it comes the the storage and the
throughput that the storage has to
deliver into this so where we are and if
you see the picture on the top left we
are sort of maxing out the spectrum of
where we could be today so for a GPU
based machine today we can go up to two
hundred eight gigs of RAM and again we
are working with Google to sort of push
that limit even higher getting it closer
to where we need to be which is in the
half a terabyte range right so today
it's sort of a dichotomy you can't get
the high end machines in GCE but you
don't get the GPUs so we sort of need
the GPUs and the the high end machines
if you and the other collaboration that
we have started on is the the cloud file
store so this is a new service that's
coming in from Google so we don't have
to be bothered with the deployment and
the management and the elasticity of the
storage solution that we've put together
ourselves so jumping into the simulators
so like I said there is a bunch of
physics that we begged into simulators
whether this is in the petroleum system
space whether this is in the economic
space
floo assurance geomechanics reservoir
engineering so we have simulators
purpose-built for each of the domains
and the kind of challenges that those
domains have and what we've done with
the the Delfy offering on Google is we
are now offering that cloud-based
dynamic compute and and what does that
really mean now I don't have to be
worried about a job queue and a fixed
HPC cluster size and how do we get a
bunch of reservoir engineers to fit
their workloads and here if a drilling
rig is becoming available and I need to
make a decision within the next couple
of days whether I want to employ this or
not I can go ahead and spin the the
nodes that is necessary not only to do
that one simulation but also many right
so here's an illustration of what a
reservoir simulation looks like so these
are the the model cells that you see
here and the two blue sticks that you
see on to the left or the injectors and
you can see that as the simulation runs
you can start to see how the water is
pushing the hydrocarbons out through the
other worlds if you will so this is one
simulation and how you can go through it
in time but what we are now able to do
with the Google infrastructure is you
can take that one aspect of it and say
what are my uncertainties what happens
if the permeability that I thought was
0.7 is actually between 0.65 and 0.75
could I run a whole bunch of these
simulations for the variability in my
uncertainty spectrum and understand what
my p10 might be 50 P 90 use cases looked
like and therefore I can start to
de-risk my estimate of the reservoir and
the flow in a much more effective manner
so obviously this gives us additional
opportunities to optimize here so what
I'm showing you here with respect to the
graph is the the white area of the graph
or basically the nodes that are active
at any given point in time
anything that is blue or the nodes that
or either being warmed up or being
passivated and the orange ones or the
ones that or idle and if you can't see
the blue and the orange ones that means
we've done a fairly good job and that is
the point here that when it comes to the
elasticity we don't want to have compute
sitting there idle right and and the
y-axis here is in the order of tens of
thousands of nodes and you can see how
effectively we are using the Google
infrastructure to map to what the
customers load is so this sort of brings
both the elasticity that they want to be
risk and deal with the uncertainties
that they are dealing with and also
bring the cost efficiency on the other
side so you're not you know ending up
paying for a HPC cluster for peak
capacity and having to deal with the
cost aspects that are associated with it
so that's it there are some challenges
in this space as well so today customers
have purpose-built HPC setup on Prem and
these are running with an infinite band
back plane if you will so effectively
because these are MPI based applications
and they have to share data for each
time step across these cells there's a
lot of communication that goes along
right so we've tried to optimize this by
trying to do a hybrid so where we can do
shared memory in in cases where the the
compute instances can be co-located in
the same node and in other cases we fall
back to network communication over NPI
and and Chris actually pointed me to the
the multi ping latency that I'm showing
you here because just like everything
else and the cloud things are constantly
changing so by the time you publish a
metric the metric is actually or so the
numbers have come down on GCE as you as
you see in the chart here it's it's a
little bit dated
so the other one that we did was we
compared this with other cloud providers
we compared this with various
configurations that we can do on Google
there were a couple of features and we
like to think that Google did this for
us
but I think it's a general benefit to
community so one is around sole tenancy
so this ensures that we can have a set
of nodes that are assigned to work
together so therefore we can bring down
the latency of the internode
communication for nodes that are part of
that sole tenancy scope they also
introduced the direct word i/o which
also shaves the latency quite a bit and
more recently with the skylake
processors and it's effective use of the
the cache and and we Numa if you work
we've effectively brought it down so if
you look at the chart on the the right
side so this is the performance variance
that I'm showing across the different
options the very first column being what
the really high-end @pc set up that
customers have on Prem versus where we
ended up with the Google compute engine
with the combination of direct Verdi or
skylake and sole tenancy right so we are
extremely close in terms of the high end
without having that huge cost of
deployment and maintenance and whatnot
right so last but not least so so far we
sort of looked at some of the technical
challenges now let's look at the
operational challenges and and first of
a shout-out to the S or a team in in
Google they spent a lot of time with us
trying to help us define where we want
to deploy these services how we want to
instrument these services from a
monitoring perspective how do we define
the right level of service level
indicators and service level objectives
figuring out the error budgets so our
operations team can be more efficient
and figuring out what are the key
problems that we need to focus on
operationally rather than going after
every problem that's going to pop up
right so today from a GPU perspective we
are in South Carolina Belgium and Taiwan
we are working with Google to expand
this to other centers and the other
regions that are out there we can
support our 2d applications but we are
waiting on the GPUs for the 3d
applications of you
so few other things so this was sort of
a necessary evil for us to solve I mean
if we went with a Google cloud storage
or a bigquery or whatever the advantage
is Google takes care of the disaster
recovery but when you overlay a shared
file system in this particular case a
ZFS file system across multiple nodes
and multiple persistent disks
effectively the meta data so the
individual persistent disks are taken
care of by Google but the overall shared
storage setup and the metadata that goes
with it we will have to take care of it
and the good thing was the ability to
have snapshots on the persistent disks
is something that came with Google for
free and it's very effective in terms of
the incremental snapshot that it
overlays and how quickly we can restore
in case there was ever a fault so the
other thing that we did was around
consistency and reliability so this was
a very important learning for us on Prem
we've gotten used to the fact that you
know machines do not go down the disks
don't fail there used to be a time when
blue screen of death was your your
day-to-day reality but that's not the
case anymore right so systems have
become much more reliable and therefore
the determinism of the availability or
the performance of a system has come to
the user as a given right but when
you're dealing with the cloud and with
the number of things that are moving
your virtual stack is way deep we have
to deal with the fact that fault
tolerance is something that we'll have
to build into the system's be able to
switch over into a different node if for
example a live migration event kicks in
and the ability for the infrastructure
to allocate a resource to you also
depends on the load on the particular
system so what I'm showing here with the
charts is we started monitoring what the
variance looks like so if I ask for a VM
to be created user comes in starts an
application how long before the
application shows up for him and the
more deterministic the less variance we
can bring into the system the better the
user experiences so this was a lot of
work that we did with the GCE team in
Google to sort of bring down that
variance that you see on the various
aspects and this is around the
availability of the system and being
able to continuously monitor this so
that way we can use our few precious
saris and operational teams to focus on
management-by-exception
rather than having to babysit these
systems right so we we leverage
stackdriver
quite a bit so we monitor both the
metrics that are coming in and we also
route all of the event logs including
the application logs into the system so
in the past you know if there was a a
crash or a performance impact on one of
our applications the customer has to
call us and let us know this is what
happened and we have to ask them okay
what data said what did you do why did
this problem happen and now effectively
what we've done is we've flipped support
on its head instead of support being
reactive it's now becoming proactive
alright so by looking at these logs
these are now creating events that
trigger and alert to the operations team
so these days by the time the customer
calls they are pleasantly surprised that
the operations team is already aware of
what's the issue that's going on and
they are actually working on it so by
the time they call they're actually
getting an estimate of when it's going
to be addressed or what a workaround is
that will restore business continuity
for a few more things on the monitoring
so this is application usage and
security so beyond what Google does in
terms of protecting the the cloud and
the infrastructure we do realize that we
have our own applications and our own
endpoints and there is extensibility on
these endpoints so what you see on the
chart on the right for example is
monitoring all the failed logins so
typically it's it's very easy to think
about the things that you want to
monitor which is the good day scenario
if you will but we also have to be very
cognizant when it comes to security on
the cloud to take care of these edge
cases so anyway - to summarize
you know this is a journey that we went
through with Google we talked about the
five challenges and how we are
effectively leveraging both Google's
expertise in this area and the Google
cloud infrastructure to tackle this and
this is a solution that's been
commercial for almost a year now and
even though I have only covered a small
portion of the challenges hopefully it
gives you a flavor for what it takes in
the oil and gas space to bring in our
software suite and bring it into a cloud
environment but on the positive side
there is a lot of advantages that our
users have got on the system already so
we talked about the reservoir simulation
and the benefits so far but you can see
both on the petro physics and on the
seismic space not only with the petrol
technical suite but also with the other
analytical solutions that we are
bringing in to supplement what the petro
technical suite does we were able to
greatly improve the productivity and
because Schlumberger is also a big-time
user of our own software for seismic
processing consulting data delivery etc
we've also improved the way we deliver
our own services right so these are some
of the stats in terms of the benefits
that the Google and Schlumberger
partnership has brought into the oil and
gas industry and I will close tying it
back to the first slide that we started
with the sort of economical pressures
that the Industries is facing today the
solution that we've put in here with
respect to automation and bringing the
efficiency is greatly appreciated by the
marketplace so I think I'm fairly out of
time but there's any questions I can
either take it now or we can take it off
[Music]